For like a day, I was thinking
maybe October would be a nice,
quiet month, but that is not panning out.
Donald Trump left Walter Reed Medical
Center yesterday via helicopter after
spending barely more than 48 hours there
in treatment for Corona virus. He arrived on
Saturday, sort of like midday, I think was about
noon or so on the East Coast, leaving yesterday
around six thirty p.m. Eastern Time. Is he cured?
No. And in fact, doctors who who have opined about
this say that this is typically or frequently a
lull in the disease before it gets much worse.
Is he contagious? Probably. But he flew back
to the White House and immediately removed
his mask. Trump in video captured with him
standing on a balcony at the White House,
which we will look out a little bit later,
visibly struggling to breathe we which we're
going to get to. But the really notable thing,
aside from having no idea the state of Donald
Trump's health in any sense whatsoever, was a
short statement that Donald Trump recorded just
outside the White House upon his arrival. Now, I
really need to give you some setup to do this with
some context. Donald Trump is on dexamethasone.
That's a steroid. It can cause euphoria,
mania, delusions of grandeur, aggressiveness,
all sorts of symptoms. Trump may have more energy
right now and may feel better for the time being,
all because of the medications that
he is on. And with that being said,
take a look at this video that Donald Trump
recorded upon his return to the White House.
I just left Walter Reed Medical Center, and
it's really something very special. The doctors,
the nurses, the first responders and
I learned so much about coronavirus.
And one thing that's for certain. Don't
let it dominate you. Don't be afraid of it.
You're going to beat it. We have the best
medical equipment. We have the best medicines
all developed recently. And you've got to beat it.
I went I didn't feel so good. And two days ago,
I could have left. Two days ago. Two days ago,
I felt great. Like better than I have in a long
time. I said just recently. Better than 20
years ago. Don't let it dominate. Don't let
it take over your lives. Don't let that happen.
So you can hear that Trump's voice is not really
there. But what he's saying is what I really
want to focus on. Don't be afraid of corona
virus. Don't let coronavirus dominate you. It's
almost like he's saying it's a personal failing.
If Corona virus hits you hard or kills you. He
decided he's not going to let it dominate him.
Of course, he has the best health care in
the world despite not paying federal taxes.
But you paying for that service that he received
through your federal taxes. He decided not to let
it dominate him. A very dangerous message. Then
he goes into kind of generic nationalist nonsense.
We're the greatest country in the world.
We're going back with him. Back to work.
Going to be OUTFRONT as your leader. I had
to do that. I knew there's danger to it,
but I had to do it. I stood out front. I led.
What does that even mean? I don't know. But I
know that there's certainly danger in Donald Trump
saying this. There is danger in it. But I had to
do it. He had to engage in risky behavior that got
him sick or he had to go to Walter Reed. What does
it mean? That there was danger, but he had to do
what? He had to keep holding rallies with large
crowds despite a raging pandemic. I don't know
what he's talking about. And Trump making less
and less sense in this video as it goes on. He
keeps going with it. Listen to this next whopper.
Nobody that's a leader would not do what I did.
And I know there's a risk. There's a danger,
but that's OK. And now I'm better.
And maybe I'm immune. I don't know.
I'm better now. And maybe I'm immune. I don't
know. We could do like an hour on that alone.
Maybe I'm immune. I don't know. Now, of course,
as a general idea, when one recovers from these
types of viruses, generally speaking, there is
immunity, at least to some degree, at least for
some period of time with this corona virus. There
are still questions about for how long are you
immune? How strong is that immunity? Is immunity
different? If you've had a more serious case or a
less serious cases, immunity different if you had
an asymptomatic case versus a symptomatic case,
a lot of questions. But why even bring this up?
And Trump actually admits he doesn't know. Maybe
I'm immune. I don't know. Completely irresponsive.
Well, in every way. And then Donald Trump,
as he's been doing frequently lately, just
repeating himself again, saying a lot of this
is not a replay. This is the end of the video.
But don't let it dominate your lives. Get out
there. Be careful. We have the best medicines
in the world. And it all happened very shortly.
And they're all getting approved and
the vaccines are coming momentarily.
Thank you very much. And Walter Reed, what
a group of people. Thank you very much.
Vaccines coming momentarily. Trump says medical
experts and public health experts, of course,
saying for the average person, vaccines are not
coming. Momentarily, Trump really does not seem
well here. He seems like he's barely hanging on
thanks to the medication. And the next few days,
it's really, you know, the next week or so is
going to be very telling. Trump really might be
on the path to kicking this up or he might get
much worse, as many do after seven to 10 days,
which would put him at this weekend. There's
actually this will sound crazy to anybody who
thinks critically and logically. But there was
a Trump adviser yesterday who said Trump plans
to be at the second debate, which is Thursday.
Next Thursday, watch plans. What does that even
mean? Plans to be? All we can do is wait and see.
He also very defiantly arrived at the White House
and removed his mask and of course, right wingers
fawning all over themselves to say he's outdoors,
he's by himself. But then he immediately
turned around and walked into the White House
and he is putting Secret Service in danger. More
employees at the White House have tested positive.
Kaley McEnany, his press secretary, has tested
positive. Rudy Giuliani did an interview on Fox
News last night. He couldn't stop coughing. We're
going to get to all of that later. But this is
all stage managed to show a triumphant, defiant
president who has decided not to let the virus
dominate him despite maybe being a super spreader
himself. And it is not it's not going to end well.
It hasn't gone well. It already hasn't gone
well, given the amount of contagion, not just
240000 or whatever. The number now is dead in
the United States, a horrifyingly high number.
Also, the White House itself becoming one of
the primary hot spots in the United States.